hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and in this video
i'm going to be revealing the five ways
that you can
drastically increase the value
of a property five hacks
refurbs things that you can do that
really really will increase the value
now i've never done a video on this
specific topic before
you've probably watched my youtube vlogs
my documentaries
you've seen me out performing
refurbishments and you may have seen
stuff but i wanted to condense this into
one video with the top
five ways that i have successfully
pushed the value
significantly up on a property by not
spending that much money as well so
if you appreciate my tips and my youtube
channel
please do me a massive favor and just
hit the like button
to show me that you enjoy my content and
then i'll keep producing more and more
videos
like this also don't forget to subscribe
and turn on the notification bell
when you're doing a refurb or when
you're trying to increase the value of
the property
it's really important that you do it the
right way sometimes people will do
things to a property they'll spend money
every time they spend a pound they'll be
increasing the value of the property by
a pound but it doesn't make any sense so
for example if you get a conservatory
it can cost 35 000 pounds to add a
conservatory to a property
you might buy a house for 200 grand
spend 35 000 pounds adding a little
conservatory
and then the new value is two three five
you know what we call that we call that
pointless
what's the point of spending a pound to
just out of a pound worth of value
what you want to do is you want to make
sure that when you're spending a pound
you're adding three pounds worth of
value
there's still some people that spend a
pound and they add 50 pence
there's some people that spend a pound
and they lose a pound
what about let me give an example you
can i i unders
water features in the garden you know
little pond and some water features
and he thought that'll be nice won't it
uh no
in fact when you put water features in
the garden it puts buyers
off because i think all that's going to
be expensive to run so you're spending
money
meanwhile you're reducing value that has
that's the opposite of what you want to
do
so i mean you could just buy a house
there's already in nice condition
and rent it out that's fine and then
you're going to wait
for the capital appreciation for the
value of the house to organically
naturally go up in time i wouldn't do
that
i would buy a house enjoy the rent but
force the value of the house up why
because then you've you've made money on
the buy you've made money on the refurb
you're making money from the rent
this is a business and you want to make
as much money as you can from it
so what are some of the things that you
can do um well for a start when you push
the value up you can
sell the house if you buy a house for
150 grand
and then you push the value up you spend
50 grand
but now it's worth 300 grand you've made
a hundred thousand pounds
you can sell the property you can get
100 grand you'll have to pay capital
uh capital gains tax on that money or
corporation tax depending on if you
bought it through a company or not but
that's one thing you can do or
what i would recommend and what my
students do is you push the value up and
then you then
refine that's the house you revalue the
house
and you borrow against the new value
meaning that you can pay off the old
mortgage
and then you can you can take out your
initial deposit
that's what you want to do now what are
some of the refurb hacks that you can do
so the first way
is look for properties that have got a
high
epc rating epc stands for energy
performance certificate so
if the energy performance certificate is
higher than a d
that property cannot be rented out now
pretty much all residential properties
across the country will have an epc
certificate how can you find out what
the current
epc certificate is online in fact if you
see a property advertised on rightmove
it will tell you what the current epc is
if it's higher than a d that property
has got an
opportunity to be pushed up in value
so if you were to say bring a a a an e
energy performance e to a to a c
you've just increased you've made it
more energy efficient
then the value of the house is going to
be
pushed up how do you do that well it
depends on the house
it might have a high energy performance
certificate because it could be that the
um the windows need to be double glazed
and they're not
and then you're letting out heat because
the windows
aren't um double glazed so you just fix
the windows and you've really
pushed the value up it could be that you
need to insulate some of the walls
it could be a whole host of things
another thing is the government
right now are giving grants
okay they're giving grants to homeowners
and landlords they're giving money to
increase
the energy performance rating so that's
a real big opportunity
number two next way is you can find a
property
that hasn't got current running hot
water this is a massive opportunity
i love it when they say there's no hot
water
sometimes they say oh there's no hot
water in the property we do have to
inform you i'm like
yes why because if it hasn't got running
hot water
it means that the property is
unmortgageable
lenders are going to be like i don't
want to lend on that house because
there's no hot water
it's crazy but it's true um work man
how can you start doing a refurb on a
property when there's no hot water
because you're going to need hot water
to do stuff like have cups of teas
builders
but other stuff so if there's no hot
water this is a big problem
fixing the hot water is very
easy normally it's just a case of
getting a new boiler which costs about
1500 pounds
and then what have you done you've
pushed the value of the house up
you've spent 1500 pounds but then you've
made a house that's unmortgageable
mortgageable you've
increased the value significantly that
is the second
opportunity that i look for the second
way to significantly increase the value
of a house
i've got three more if you're enjoying
it so far don't forget i hope you've hit
like i hope that blue
thumb is is pointing up and i hope it's
blue okay number three
is you can turn a
residential single let property a family
home
you can change its use into a
hmo a house in multiple occupancy
how do you do this well it depends on
the house let's say you've got a three
bedroom house with two reception rooms
all you need to do is you need to put
fire doors
furniture you need to register it as a
hmo
rent it out on a room by room basis and
now you've changed its use
now the rents are going to be
significantly higher instead of the rent
maybe being
700 pounds you're now getting maybe 1700
pounds
what does it mean when the rents are
significantly higher it means
that the value of the property is higher
typically a
a property will have two valuations it
will have the bricks and mortar
valuation
and it will have the commercial
valuation based on rent if you can
significantly increase the rent it's
going to increase the value of
the property so that is way number three
uh by the way there's other things you
can do similar to this you could for
instance you could turn a large
victorian property you could
title split it into apartments you take
a big property
split it into apartments and that can
massively increase the
the value if you do it in the right area
again area is really really important um
i'll give you an example
there are some properties where um you
might
get a loft conversion okay if you've got
a property in
doncaster in the north you could spend
50 000 pounds getting a loft conversion
but then only increase the value by 20
000 pounds
because there's a ceiling price on
houses
in that area however if you were to do a
loft conversion in
london and you would you would get a get
a loft
in the house then you might spend 50 60
000 pounds but you might add
300 000 pounds to the value because
space is so much more valuable and
limited in certain areas so that's
something to really look at when you're
title splitting as well
okay number four are we on number four i
think we are on number four number four
is if you've got a problem tenant so if
you've got a tenant in a property who's
not paying rent who's a squatter
an issue with a tenant or if the
property is just empty and it's not
rentable
again massive massive problem who wants
to buy a house with a problem temp let
me tell you a story there was a property
in wolverhampton
it was about the value of it was about
120 000 pounds
there was a tenant in there that wasn't
paying rent a terrible nightmare tenant
and the the owner couldn't sell the
house and the agent was saying oh
you know the tenant's been very
difficult they're not letting viewings
come in they're not even paying rent it
was a
nightmare i bought the property for
80 000 pounds that is a significant
discount that's like
40 000 pounds off the price why
just because there was a bad tenant in
there the owner needed the money
they were stressed out about the tenant
what did i then do
as soon as i completed i paid the bad
tenant 1 000 pounds to disappear i was
like look
here's a grand off right
the tenant left so i've made 40 grand
because of the tenant and giving them a
grand i mean it's it's crazy
so if you know how to get rid of tenants
now you could say what happens if they
haven't have left
they will leave at the right price okay
i know how to evict tenants as well
okay what i did by the way there was
completely legal but i know how to evict
tenants i know the law
i've got a team that deal with it some
people don't if you've got a landlord
that's got a tenant that's not paying
rent and they're really stressed out
they don't have to deal with it
you can get a really good price and then
get rid of them and then what have you
done
push the value up on the house
number five which is really really
really um simple and straightforward
is if there's a property that hasn't got
a nice or hasn't got a
any kitchen or bathroom if there's a
property that's not got a kitchen or
bathroom but it's got a really ugly
kitchen bathroom
it doesn't cost a lot to fix the kitchen
or bathroom the kitchen is the most
important room in the house
if there's no kitchen or if the
kitchen's really shabby it costs
1500 pounds on average to get a nice
kitchen from somewhere like howden's or
magnet nice kitchen
it's probably gonna cost you another
fifteen hundred pounds to get someone to
fit it that's
three grand for a nice beautiful looking
kitchen now it's not high-end
but it looks nice three grand
if there's no kitchen or really ugly
kitchen and you spend three grand and
getting the kitchen done
you're probably going to push the value
up by 10 15 or even more thousand pounds
does that fit with the rule yes it does
spend a pound add three pound value to
the property
so those are the top five ways that i
like to add value to properties
if i've missed anything that you've
succeeded in or if you've got any other
suggestions or ideas
then please comment it below in the
comments
and i look forward to sharing more with
you top tips i do a
youtube video every single day people
say how do you do that
it's not hard because i'm out doing
deals all the time and then i'll just
share
um share once a day what's going on so
uh if you want to see more videos
like this you can check out a video
right here which i think you'll really
enjoy
also if you want to join me at the
property investors crash course
you can do that it's free on the house
where you can learn everything i know
about property
condensed into a day you can attend that
for free and also don't forget to
subscribe up here
thanks for watching i'll see you next
time